okay let's do it go baby go
I like the noises this baby's
weight like ducks quacking why did it
just stop them it stops right well it's
stopping for people and I think that's
great okay right now we're stopped
because this if there's a mob the
students coming back and forth and
they're not getting out of our way
because they think we're stopped can I
give you a ride my brother's car
purchase a few minutes who do you think
you would trust more driving the car or
the computer I have my touch what part
do you think the car played in that a
hundred percent
so what sort of things can you do in a
car if you don't be driving maybe you
could use your cell phone if you wanted
to that's a danger right now isn't it
I'm gonna text like IRA text hey if you
were single and had a girl with you your
hands would be free
about it what was the first car either
of you owned
mine was a Plymouth sedan my first car
was the car that I stole for my father
Dave Ford v8 for a lion convertible it
was so cool
the 1967 Buick Skylark so how is this
car different well I had to drive it
there were no seat belts invented yet
that was the dark ages didn't have seat
belts that was new thing now this
reminds me of the cartoons of Aladdin on
his magic carpet it reminds me of one of
my dreams come true to be a part of the
outer space program where me your bright
boy okay because you won't let me drive
anymore we survived was there ever a
doubt that you weren't gonna make it
before we got what if it decided to
drive off the end of the pier we didn't
hit anyone all day that's great you can
let the squirrels out now